and more positive news in the fight
against covet 19 the fda gave emergency
authorization for eli
lilly's antibody treatment after data
showed the therapeutic reduced the risk
of hospitalization among coveted
patients david lee miller live for us in
new york city with more on this and
david lee what can you tell us
good morning trace well this drug is
called bam
lane of a map it was recently used by
the former new jersey governor chris
christie
and a similar treatment was given to
president trump
the drug works by preventing the virus
from entering human cells
it is only for patients with a mild form
of the virus it is not to be used for
patients requiring hospitalization
or using oxygen the company in a press
release said and i quote
bam laina vimab should be administered
as soon as possible after
a positive covet 19 test and within 10
days of symptom
onset by the end of the year the
manufacturer says it expects to have 1
million doses available worldwide the
u.s has a contract for
300 000 doses at a cost of 375 million
dollars
antibody treatments like this one are
considered one of the best ways
to treat the virus until there is a
vaccine yesterday pfizer you might
recall reported
an initial effectiveness rate of 90
percent on its vaccine and said it could
seek emergency
authorization from the fda by the end of
the month and this morning the health
and human services secretary
addressed its distribution
so the timeline is pfizer will be
producing and delivering to us
approximately 20 million doses of
vaccine
each month starting at the end of this
month in november
meanwhile the virus continues to rage
yesterday it hit a new milestone
more than 10 million americans have now
been infected the infections continue to
rise in nearly
every state and with thanksgiving now
only weeks away
the cdc has issued a number of
guidelines and suggestions for people to
follow
they say that at the celebrations uh
only one person should
serve the food and that person should
wear a mask you should limit the size of
the celebrations try and have them
outdoors
and here's when you may not have thought
of try and keep
music low so people don't have to shout
and possibly spread the virus trace or
sing
david lee miller live for us in new york
city david lee thanks